hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
this is gonna be a bit of a bonus video
as I'm actually preparing to go to
Europe in a couple of days and had all
my videos lined up for the next five
weeks the news just broke about Elon
Musk's neural link so I thought I would
make a video No
so when I first heard about the neural
link a few years ago I thought it was
pie in the sky but after watching the
presentation and thinking about it a
little bit a lot of this stuff has
actually been done before it's nothing
new it's just been done a lot better so
let's take a look at what the neural
link is how it works and the new feature
that we could all be facing you are
watching ColdFusion TV
[Music]
in July of 2019 Elon Musk had a
presentation detailing the neural link
project earlier in the year on the Joe
Rogan podcast musk said that those are
big announcement coming and this was it
so what is the neural link must states
that human cognition has two major
systems the limbic system where our
emotions needs and once are processed
and then the cortex which involves
thinking and planning the neural link in
its final form is to be a third layer on
top of this a digital super intelligence
layer augmenting ourselves with
computers and eventually artificial
intelligence depending on how you look
at it we already have this layer in the
form of our phones and laptops you've
all heard the saying that we have all of
the world's information at our
fingertips the bottleneck and all of
this is how we interface with that
information fingers and speech are too
slow and a very low bandwidth form of
communication between us and our devices
a much faster way to get to this
information would be directly this is
called the brain machine interface and
the neural link is an effort to solve
this problem it's already been a massive
multidisciplinary effort it includes
scientists doctors electrical engineers
surgeons and more so how does it work so
our brain consists of neurons firing all
the time in response to electrical
signals sent when we see here move talk
or think whenever a neuron fires from
these electrical signals a tiny
electromagnetic field is present
basically neural link is going to tap
into these tiny electric fields
generated as sinus junctions in the
brain it's going to interpret this
analog data as ones and zeros to be used
in the digital world the neuron pulses
will be detected using tiny threads
about one-tenth the cross section of a
human hair or about the size of a neuron
each thread is to be installed with a
robot so it's not going to burst blood
vessels or cause trauma
the needle for insertion is 24 microns
in diameter much smaller than the
state-of-the-art in deep brain
stimulation such surgeries had been done
before for deep brain stimulation for
Parkinson's sufferers though these
traditional methods have a 1 in 100
chance of causing a severe brain
hemorrhage a smaller footprint should
make things much safer the state of the
art for Parkinson's deep brain
stimulation has around 10 electrodes the
neural link contains thousands of
electrodes these electrodes need to be
less than 60 microns away to detect a
fire in neuron and serve as the
interface that reads data from the brain
and sends data to the brain
the processor for making all of this
work is something called the n1 chip the
n1 chip reads analog brain signals
amplifies them digitizes them processes
them and then sends it out to a pot
device behind the ear the pod device is
the only thing that's going to be
upgraded and the implant stay as they
are
remove the pod and everything shuts off
the n1 chip is 4 by 5 millimeters
low-power and has built-in hardware for
processing brain signals it can read
20,000 brain samples per second so these
are real raw signals coming from a
neural link hooked up to a brain
what the scientists are looking for a
spikes in voltage when a neuron fires
this is the fundamental element of
communication within the brain an
algorithm can detect these spikes in
real-time decode them and make sense
that the vast amounts of data coming in
the system can not only read data from
the brain but also write data to do this
a signal is run through an electrode
near a neuron causing that neuron to
fire this kind of thing again isn't new
and has been done since the late 1950s
it's actually the basic technologies
behind the cochlear implant the one that
helps restore hearing
the information inputted into the brain
doesn't have to be perfect because of
neuroplasticity this means the brain
learns how to use the new information
reading data from the brain and
inputting data into the brain can be an
already kind of has been used to treat
things like Parkinson's and epilepsy but
future applications can include things
as far as depression and chronic pain
further applications could increase
cognitive function and memory
[Music]
the original plan for the neural link is
to connect for n1 chips with thousands
of electrodes are coming from each chip
signals will be sent via bluetooth to
the pod device behind the ER and it will
be controlled by a phone the first goal
is to get patients to be able to control
a mobile device a phone mouse or
computer keyboard the neural link will
show up as a regular Bluetooth keyboard
or mouse they want to make people fully
independent of their caretakers
this sounds lofty but has already been
done before with a technology called the
Utah Rae with only just a hundred
electrodes patients are able to text
other people and control tablets with
their mind
remember the neural link has thousands
of electrodes resulting in a cleaner
more reliable signal for more complex
applications the first application for
the neural link is to tap into the
primary motor cortex the part of the
brain that sends signals down to the
spinal cord and onto the muscles to
drive the movement it will start with
simple things like a mouse and keyboard
but could also be used to read signals
from all movement even speech and
finally it could be used to restore
movement of someone's own body the
materials science team wants to use
materials or properties that would make
the brain not only accept the neural
link but think that it's part of itself
the team has already released a paper of
reading recording and studying data from
brains using their n1 chip it's fairly
controversial but early tests on monkeys
have been successful we wish that we
didn't have to work with animals right
that we just wish that wasn't like a
step in the process and we try to be
very careful and thoughtful about it and
do it as efficiently as possible because
we believe that the benefit to humanity
is is in the end like about the benefits
outweigh the negatives yeah but we have
had made a uh you know monkey has been
able to control the computer with his
brain just yeah
why I didn't really started running that
result today but there it goes human
patient trials are set to start by the
end of 2020 the target patient will be a
quadriplegic due to a spinal cord injury
the main hurdle so far has been FDA
approval for implantable devices so the
future of neural link will be in three
stages Stage one is to understand and
treat brain disorders starting with
people with serious medical needs stage
to preserve and enhance one's own brain
Stage three full brain machine
interfaces in the future that could even
be a kind of app store for programs that
you can download and control your brain
other possibilities from the
presentation include a new kind of
communication kind of like telepathy or
downloading the memories of someone
who's familiar with a city so that when
you go to that city you feel familiar
with it too the possibility is a kind of
endless but of course these are the very
early days and we hardly understand
anything about the brain right now
although what the neural link is basing
itself off has already been done in the
medical field for decades what they're
proposing is a giant leap above all of
that and it's going to be a long road to
get there
says some obvious questions remain is
this ethical should we do this what
about the risks well for that last one
in terms of risks for Parkinson's deep
brain stimulation and other such
procedures seem to be much more risky
though there's not a lot known about
what the kind of technology that neural
link is proposing could lead to in its
full form so what do you guys think do
you think it's an interesting idea and
should be pursued or do you have some
kind of reservations I'm gonna leave my
opinion out of this one let me know in
the comment section below so thanks for
watching I hope you learned something
from this it's definitely an interesting
time we're living in at the moment
if you want to see more stuff like this
or anything on the lines of business
science technology and history
definitely subscribe to cold fusion
you'll find a lot of interesting stuff
here and don't forget to check out the
cold fusion podcast I'll leave a link
for that below so thanks for watching
this has been together and you've been
watching cold fusion and I'll catch you
again soon for the next video cheers
guys have a good one cold fusion it's
losing
[Music]
you